these celebrities invited to make these
annual presentations are chosen by a
committee by definition a committee is a
group of people all of whom cannot make
it on Thursday those who did show up
decided the next award should be
presented by a talented lady in a new
dramatic actor I won't tell you which is
which but their names are Phyllis Diller
and Milton Berle
we're delighted to present the
documentary film awards aren't we Welton
mm-hmm why did you mention Milton now
they know which is which
are you ready to begin Phil Phyllis
Phyllis there may be some doubts I may
be one of the doubters now would you
start please for the best feature-length
documentary production the nominations
are the Battle of the Bulge the brave
rifles mascot productions Lauren C
mascot producer the Eleanor Roosevelt
story a Sydney glacier production Sydney
glazier producing the Forth Road Bridge
random film productions limited Peter
mills producers let my people go
Walter productions Marshall farm
produces to die in Madrid and senex
productions Frederick Ross if producer
oh yes thank you will you opened it yes
coming mr. dillert the winner is
the Eleanor Roosevelt story Sydney
glazier
thank you very much I'd like to just do
an inadequate thank you to the 27
countries of the world it's applied some
of the material for the film to the
museum our film editor who spent many a
lonely night to ezra Latterman who wrote
a sensitive and beautiful score but most
of all to one of America's outstanding
poets and playwrights who wrote an
original screenplay that became the
heartbeat in the discipline for the
Eleanor Roosevelt story Archibald
MacLeish thank you very
now for the best achievement in
documentary production of short subjects
the nominations are mural on our street
Henry Street Settlement Kirk Smallman
productions overture a mouth film
production point of view a vision
associates production to be alive SC
Johnson Francis Thompson producer Yeats
country Angus films for the Department
of External Affairs of Ireland
Patrick Carey and Joe Mendoza producers
don't be funny signed Bob Hope
sorry wrong envelope it was handed to me
as I came
sorry Mike thank you winner the winner
is to be alive Francis
I thank the members of the Academy for
the very great honor they've conferred
upon us this evening and I thank them in
behalf of Alexander Hamad my co-director
of gene Ferrell who did the musical
score and of the whole group of people
the earnest filmmakers who worked so
hard to make this moment possible for us
I also want to say a special word of
thanks to mr. Herbert Johnson of
johnson's wax who commissioned the film
and who gave us complete creative
freedom during its production I only
hope that other filmmakers in our kind
of work have as great an opportunity as
we thank you very much
there they go
Sonny and Cher of Sun City